so across the pond spaz is short for
[ __ ] the spaz that I grew up with as
a teenager in the 90s I'm
being like a total laundry spaz he's as
fast where it meant that you were like
maybe a little bit random it could even
be in terms of endearment
is not the same as the spaz that's used
in African-American vernacular English
where it basically means that you're
about to fight somebody so we don't use
that term in the U.S the way that they
do in the UK which is where uh this
shortening to Spas has become the
equivalent of a slur probably the
closest analog in American English is
like [ __ ] it carries that type of
weight in early summer 2022 lizzo was
called out by an Australian activist for
using the word spaz in her new song
girls lizzo made sure to emphasize that
she herself as a fat black woman in
America had experienced oppression and
language-based oppression she did sort
of remind this activist from Australia
which side her Progressive bread was
buttered on I've had many hurtful words
used against me so I understand the
power words can have lizzo said in a
statement posted to Instagram I'm proud
to say there's a new version of girls
with a lyric change hold my bed
just seven weeks later Beyonce operated
for using a similar phrase spazzing on
that ass in her song heated
fans never heard from Beyonce herself
because lizzo sort of primed the pump
for her Beyonce didn't I think really
have much of a choice to be responsive
in the way that she was
two major artists altered the lyrics to
their songs they erased the word spaz in
post-production after the album had
already been released after activists
from Australia and other locations
across the pond where spaz is a much
worse word than it is in the U.S
objected and said that it was ableist
this is a rapidly advancing New Frontier
for the suppression of free speech and
artistic expression Rosenfield writes in
a new article for reason magazine stop
spazzing out about spaz it's something
Beyond burning books something Beyond
destruction it's stories and songs and
films cut apart and written over leaving
no trace and no remnant of whatever used
to be it wasn't unheard of for an artist
to alter their lyrics after the fact you
could expect them to respond to you that
they were sort of a moral Authority this
idea that you needed to be able to look
up to artists not just because you
enjoyed the art they made but because
they were supposed to represent some
kind of a role model to you as the
listener they're supposed to reflect
your values you know morally politically
Etc I think that people got not just
used to but maybe a little bit drunk on
the realization that if they made enough
noise they could kind of emotionally
blackmail artists who were concerned
with reputation management
into doing their bidding on the one hand
people who like music or like books who
like to consume culture and on the other
hand you have people who want to control
culture who want to go back to the
artist and say I don't like what you did
here it offends me change it there is
virtually no overlap between these two
groups they have completely separate
sets of motivations completely separate
things that they're trying to achieve
when they engage with the given award
artists are left with the Nexus of this
where they want to be creating work for
the former people people who genuinely
like art but they are subject to the
whims and the punishments the
consequences meted out by the latter
group and I don't think that this is a
great environment in which to be trying
to create much of anything let alone
create it bravely Swift's new video for
her song anti-hero is facing controversy
over a song where she steps on a scale
that reads fat critics are saying she's
promoting so-called fat phobia but her
supporters are pointing out how she's
always been open about her struggle with
her own eating disorders and the video
reflects what she sees not what you see
her seeing Taylor Swift chose to alter
the scene in her music video where she
is standing on a scale that reads fat to
her just simply staring at her
disruptive and disapproving doppelganger
this actually strikes me as maybe the
most tragic example of this happening
you know on a contemporary landscape
because here is a case of not just a
word being used in context by one person
where another person says well in our
culture that's offensive this is a woman
talking about her own personal history
revealing something that is painful
about herself and exploring that through
her art and the idea that she is going
to be scolded and made to change her
work because other people didn't like
the way that she was negotiating her own
pain in her artwork that just strikes me
as wildly inappropriate by being able to
pull back your original work and change
it in real time so that the digital copy
that gets released on streaming services
which is the way that most people Now
consume music is not just different but
it seems like it's always been that way
it's basically creating a second reality
and there's a sense now that maybe
nothing is permanent art isn't going to
be permanent anymore that it will update
itself in accordance with contemporary
sensibilities so if some something and
it becomes offensive well we don't have
to reckon with that as an artifact of an
earlier time anymore it is Insidious
that this is happening in such a hidden
way there's no bonfire of books if
somebody like Beyonce does not take a
stand on her right to create as she
pleases there's very very little hope
for anybody else including artists who
are just emerging who are just
developing and trying to take risks but
can't we're too afraid to